في الولايات المتحده يزيد الصراع
الانتخابيه حماسا كلما اقترب الموعد
والجديد جاء من تصريح المفاجئ لنائب رئيس
الامريكي السابق مايك بانس موجها اياه
لترامب قائلا التاريخ سيحاسبك على دورك في
هجوم الكابيتال هذه التصريحات ستؤدي بحسب
مراقبين الى تعميق الخلافات بين المرشحين
السابقين منذ ان رفض بانسا المشاركه في
جهود ترامب لالغاء نتائج انتخابات 2020
والبقاء في السلطه باد في كلمه القاها في
حفل العشاء في واشنطن يقيمه صحفيون سنويا
للقاء كبار السياسيين قال ان الرئيس ترامب
كان مخطئا مضيفا تصريحات تراب المتهوره
عرضت عائلتي وكل شخص في الكابيتال للخطر
في ذلك اليوم
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تصريحات
خطيره لمايك بينس تضع مستقبل ترامب
السياسيه على المحاك المنافسه داخل الحزب
الجمهوري تشتد لنيل الثقه للترشح في
الانتخابات المقبله هذه المره مايك بينس
يدخل في خط المواجهه ويكثف من انتقاداته
لمثير الشغب والترامب هجوم مبنى الكابيتول
عام 2021 هو الباب الامثل ليدخل منه في
صراعه مع ترامب
بتعريض عائلته والجميع في مبنى الكابيتال
للخطر بل اكد ان ترامب كان مخطئا للدعائه
ان كان لديه سلطه الغاء نتائج الانتخابات
عام 2020 تعليقات وصفت بالحاده حول دور
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب في الهجوم على
مبنى الكابيتال مع فتح وزاره العدل البابا
امام مقاضاه ترامب في مسؤوليته عن هج وم
الكابيتال لم يفوت بانس الفرصه في الهجوم
على الترامب بعدما كان يرفض التعاون مع
لجنه مجلس النواب المعنيه بالتحقيق في
الهجوم